المترجم: Ahmed Almassri
المدقّق: muhammad Samir
السلام عليكم
سأبدأ بسؤال
علبة فارغة
ماذا تعني لأي إنسان منا؟
بشكل عام
لا شيء
وهو بالفعل لا تعني أي شيء
لأي إنسان في ظرف طبيعي
لكن هذه العلبة أو مثلها
كان لها قيمة اعتبارية كبيرة
لاختلاف الزمان والمكان
سأعود لها بعد قليل
لأخبركم قصتها
قبل ذلك
كل إنسان منا
يملك ألبوم صور
يحمل فيه ذكرياته
جزء منها سعيد
يتمنى لو أنها كانت طويلة
جزء منها قاسي مؤلم
يحمد الله عزوجل أنه تجاوزها
سأستعرض معكم ألبوم
صوري
عدد قليل من ألبوم صوري وذكرياتي
قد يكون مختلف بعض الشيء
الصورة الأولى صورتي سنة 1992
كنت مثلي مثل أي شاب فلسطيني
يحاول أن يبحث عن هوية
يدافع عن وطنه
عن شعبه
كان عمري 19 سنة
أُصبت بعيار ناري متفجر
دخل من ظهري وخرج من صدري
في الرئة اليمنى
اعتقلت وأنا مصاب
كان يفترض أن يتم تقديم العلاج لي
بشكل طبيعي
تم تقديم العلاج بين قوسين (بعملية جراحية)
استمرت مدة ساعتين لاستخراج شظايا
لكن العملية كانت بدون تخدير
بدون بنج
وهذه كانت بداية رحلتي التي
استمرت 20 سنة
بعدها بأيام كان لي قصة مع هذا الرقم
هل حاول أحد قراءته
الرقم غير مألوف
ليست جائزة اليانصيب
ليس تعداداً سكانياُ
لأحدى الدول
هذا الرقم كان الحكم الذي صدر بحقي
من المحكمة العسكرية
تصفيق
ثماني تسعات متكررة
هكذا كتب في ورقة الحكم
تسع وتسعون مليوناً
وتسعمائة وتسع وتسعون ألفاً
وتسعمائة وتسع وتسعون
سنة
مؤبد مدى الحياة
وكان من المفترض بشكل طبيعي
أن أقضي هذه المدة
لكن حكم الله غالب
كان يفترض أن أقضي هذا الوقت
حياً أو ميتاً
وهذه مفارقة
لو قدر لي أن أموت في السجن
كنت سأحول إلى
ما يسمى مقابر الأرقام
لن تسلم جثتي إلى أهلي
لكن مرة أخرى
قدر الله غالب
تصفيق
بعدها مباشرة
بعد الحكم مباشرة
تحول اسمي من أحمد إلى
هذا الرقم
هل قرأه أحد
مليون وأربعة وأربعون ألفاً
وستة ثلاثون
وستة وثلاثون
رقم الأسير
تحول اسمي من أحمد الفليت إلى
مليون وأربعة وأربعون ألفاً وستة وثلاثون
كنت أنادى به ثلاث مرات بشكل يومي
365 يوما في السنة
20 ألف مرة نوديت بهذا الرقم
ومن المفارقات
بعدها مباشرة
ثم نقلي إلى زنزانة عزل انفرادي
في قسم تحت الأرض
زنزانة مترين في مترين
أول شخص التقيته
حاول رفع معنوياتي
" شد حيلك، كن قوي، اصمد"
كان رجل كبير في السن
ومبتسم
سألته كم قضيت في السجن
قال لي "19"
قلت له يعني سنة ونصف؟
ظننت على عدد الأشهر فقلت له
سنة ونصف تقريباً
قال لي " بل 19 سنة"
19 سنة
عمري
سألته عن تاريخ ميلاده
كان تاريخ ميلاده
عفواً سألته عن تاريخ اعتقاله
كان تاريخ اعتقاله قبل تاريخ ميلادي
بصراحة صُدمت
وفي نفس الوقت
استصغرت نفسي
19 سنة، معنويات عاليةـ،
وأنا كان لي 4 شهور
تنهيدة مع تصفيق
في هذا الموقف
كان لابد من إتخاذ قرار
إما الصبر والصمود والتحدي
البحث عن معنى حياة
التشبث ببصيص أمل
أو الاستسلام
الاستسلام كان بيعني حكم شخصي
بالإعدام والموت
في تلك الظروف بدأنا نبحث
عن أي نوع من أنواع الحياة
نحاول أن نخرج من جدران الزنزانة
بأي وسيلة من الوسائل
صورة حقيقية
ماذا يوجد في الصورة
الصورة سليمة بالمناسبة
كما ترونها
صورة القمر
كنا نراه من الزنزانة
من شباك الزنزانة
من فتحة مساحتها سبعة سم
بشكل قطري إلى الأعلى بهذا الشكل
كنا سعيدين جداً جداً
عندما نستطيع مشاهدته
كنا نقف تباعاً على شباك الزنزانة
حتى نرى القمر بهذا الشكل
وكنا محظوظين جداً
وبعدما يختفي
كنا نواصل حديثنا عن
" المغامرة" التي رأيناها
كنا نخبر زملاءنا المتواجدين
في الزنزانة المقابلة
أننا رأينا القمر
كانوا يشعرون بالحسرة لعدم تواجدهم
في المكان الذي نتواجد فيه
في الزنزانة المقابلة
كي يروا ما رأيناه
عملية بحثنا عن أي
نوع من أنواع الحياة
كانت تتم بأي طريقة
كمية الطعام التي كانت تقدم لنا
في بعض الأوقات
بالكاد كانت تكفي أن
نبقى على قيد الحياة
مع ذلك كنا نلقي جزء
من أكلنا خارج شباك الزنزانة
على أمل أن يأتي نوع من أنواع الطيور
حتى نستطيع رؤيته
وفي حال نجاحنا
كنا نلقي أكبر كمية من الطعام
للطيور أو العصافير
تصفيق
في بعض الأحيان
كنا نصادف عصفور صغير
وقع بأي شكل من الأشكال
في حال أننا لم ننقذه
كان مصيره الموت
كنا نأخذه إلي الزنزانة
ونطعمه بهذا الشكل
نذوب له الطعام في فمنا
حتى يبقى على قيد الحياة
تصفيق مع تنهيدة
في المفارقات
كنا سعداء جدا ونحن نراه
يكبر أمامنا حتى يتمكن من الطيران
كنا نمنحه الحرية التي
حرمنا منها
تصفيق
نطيره من الشباك
لكن وكأنه شعر أن حاجتنا لوجوده بيننا
أشد من حاجته لمن ينقذ حياته
فكان يعود اختياريا لداخل الزنزانة
ويألفنا ويبقى معنا داخل الزنزانة
تصفيق
كان هو مدار حديثنا
في النهاية كنا بشر داخل الزنزانة
ألفنا وجوه بعض
حفظنا قصص بعضنا
فكان مدار حديثنا هو العصفور
وأذكر موقف واحد من الأسرى
دعس على العصفور
فمات
بدون مبالغة
كان حزننا على العصفور كأننا
فقدنا أحد زملاءنا
تنهيد مع تصفيق
كل طاولة أمامكم عليها برتقالة
من أكلها؟
غير الدكتور عبد الرؤوف
من أكل البرتقالة؟
لماذا لم تأكلوها؟
من أمسكها؟
من سأل عن سبب وجودها؟
قصة البرتقالة؟
طبعاً صورتي مع البرتقالة
قصتها مر وقت طويل جداً
على آخر مرة تدخل لنا فواكه
أي نوع من أنواع الفواكه
كنا عشرة أسرى
أتوا لنا بخمس برتقالات
كنا سعداء جداً
كان قرار بدون نقاش
لن نقوم بأكلها
نريد أن نمسك البرتقالة
نحسها، نشمها، نلمسها
لدرجة أن من ينام
تنام البرتقالة بجانبه
وعند اقتراب تلفها
كنا نأكلها
هذه قصة البرتقالة
التي سأل أغلبكم عن سبب وجودها
مرور الوقت والروتينية
بطبيعة البشر
ستفقدني قيمة الشعور بالأشياء
أغلبنا سأل عن سبب وجودها
لكن ما شعر بقيمتها بشكل فعلي
كنا محتاجين للمس البرتقالة
نشاهد العصور ويكون بيدنا
كنا نحاول إيجاد أي نوع
من أنواع الحياة
في مرة من المرات
نجحنا وبمغامرة
أن نعمل مزرعة
كان نصفها بصل
والنصف الآخر ورد
داخل الزنزانة
أتحبون مشاهدتها؟
تصفيق مع تنهيد
يستمر التصفيق
مزرعتنا السعيدة
طبعاً كانت مغامرة
البصلة كانت جاية للأكل
انتبهنا أنها بدأت تنمو
فقررنا نعمل مغامرة
ونكمل إنباتها
أتينا بكوب وقليل من القطن
وبعض التراب
طلعت البصلة
كنا سعداء جداً
أنه عندنا شيء أخضر نراه
بالمناسبة، الأصل في المكان الذي كنا فيه
المنع، والاستثناء المسموح
لذلك كنا سعداء جداً بالبصلة
الوردة كانت أكبر من مستوى طموحنا
أو أملنا أو توقعاتنا لكن
بمغامرة حصلنا على الوردة
لم يكن هناك مجال لكوب آخر
أو قطن أو تراب
فوضعناهما معاً
ولم نجد أي تناقض
في وجود الوردة والبصلة في
نفس المكان
بالعكس كنا سعداء جداً جداً
وحريصين جداً جداً
أن تستمر عندنا أكبر وقت ممكن
مزرعتنا السعيدة
تصفيق
على ذكر البصل
في فترة من الفترات
ولوقت طويل جداً
كان فطورنا وغذاؤنا
وعشاؤنا يحتوي على البصل
فتراكم عندنا بشكل كبير جداً
استخدمناه بكل الطرق
مطبوخ، مسلوق، مشوي، مقلي
حتى عملناه مخلل
مخلل بصل
مع ذلك
بقي منه ولم يكن بمقدورنا رميه
كمية الطعام محدودة جدا
فابتكرنا شيء بحيث نستفيد منه
دون رميه
فصنعنا منه حلويات
تصفيق
وفي العيد، كان جزء من حلويات العيد
مكون بشكل أساسي من البصل
على ذكر العيد
وهو اليوم الأصعب والأقسى
والذي كان يمر علينا في ذلك المكان
ماذا يعني العيد لإنسان
بعيد عن أهله، عن أمه،
عن أبيه، عن أحبابه، عن أصدقائه
بعضنا ولمدة عشرين سنة لم يكن يعرف حتى
مصير أهله!
مع ذلك، حتى في ذاك اليوم
كان علينا أن نكون أقوياء
كنا نشدّ من أزر بعضنا
نحاول أداء مناسك العيد
بأي وسيلة من الوسائل
حسب الظروف الممكنة
بالإضافة للحلويات التي كانت
مكونة بشكل أساسي من البصل
كنا نعمل كعك العيد
كان لا بد من توفير كعك العيد
كل مرة (عيد)
كعك العيد كان بدون سميد، بدون طحين،
بدون عجوة ولابد أن يكون موجوداً
تصفيق
أشياء صغيرة
لكن هذه التي
كانت عاملاً مساعداً لنا
في المكان الذي كنا فيه
والبيئة التي كنا فيها
أن نتشبث ولو ببصيص أمل
هل تحبون أن تعرفوا قصة العلبة؟
في بداية اعتقالي كنت في زنزانة
ليس فيها شيء
ملابسي التي ألبسها فقط
كنت أحاول الخروج بروحي، بعقلي
من جدران الزنزانة
كنت أحاول اللجوء للقراءة
لكن لم يكن هناك كتبا
كانوا يأتوا لنا أحياناً
أكل في معلبات
كنت أحتفظ بالعلبة الفارغة
ولا أرميها
أبدأ بقراءة المكونات
المركبات،
أحياناً بلغة أعرفها،
أحياناً وغالباً
لم أكن أعرفها
أستمر بحفظ المكونات
حتى أتمكن من الحصول على علبة أخرى مختلفة
ثم أبدأ بقراءة مكوناتها وأحفظها
بهذه الوسيلة كنت أخرج على الأقل بعقلي
من جدران الزنزانة
في هذا المكان
أخذت قراراً
بتعلم اللغة العبرية لأن أغلب الكتابة
كانت باللغة العبرية
تعلمتها خلال عشرين يوماً
وأتقنتها وبدأت أعلمها لزملائي
تصفيق
أول جملة ركبتها
كانت مثلاً باللغة العبرية
كان يحكي بالعبري
" إندابار هاعوميت بفني هاراتسون"
معناه بالعربية
لا شيء يقف أمام الإرادة
تصفيق
حاولت استحضار هذه الكلمات
في رحلة عشرين سنة
مررنا خلالها بلحظات ضعف
لكننا لم نصل لمرحلة الانكسار أبدا
في فترة من الفترات
استطعنا الالتحاق بالجامعة
أكملنا من خلالها أنا وزملائي
دراستنا الأكاديمية
بشكل شخصي، أنهيت دراستي
في البكالوريوس تخصص علاقات دولية
وفي الماجيستير
تخصص إدارة عامة
بفضل بداية من هذه العلبة
تصفيق
أريد الحديث عن قصة
مرور الوقت أفقدنا القدرة على تصور
الأشياء
عندما أُدخل إلينا البرتقال
لم نكن نعرف
هل هي مثلجة أم هذا هو وقتها
مع ذلك لم تكن مشكلة كبيرة
بالنسبة لنا
في إحدى زيارات الأهالي
والدتي كانت جالسة بجانبي
وطفل يمشي
أقول لها
الطفل يمشي
نظرت فيه ثم نظرت إلي
وقالت: وما المشكلة؟
قلت لها: كم عمره؟
ردت علي بسؤال وقالت:
كم تقدر عمره أنت؟
تصوري كان أن عمره عدة شهور
فردت علي: إن عمره 4 سنوات
على الأقل
هذا الموقف تكرر معي ومع زملائي
وصلنا لدرجة
كنا فيها بسبب تكرر مثل هذه المواقف
نشعر بقيمة العصفور ومعناه
قيمة البصلة والجزء الأخضر منها
قيمة الوردة
قيمة رؤيتي للقمر
قيمة حديثي مع زملائي
أشياء نملكها جميعاً
لكن
الروتينية
وطبيعة البشرتجعلنا دائماً
نبحث عن ما لا نملك
كنا نستحضر دائماً
حتى عندما نكون في ذلك الظرف
قول الله عزوجل:" وإنْ تعُدُّوا
نِعمَةَ اللَّه لَا تُحصُوها"
كلنا نملك سمعاً، وبصراً
قادرين على الشم
قادرين على الأكل
كلنا نتحكم أو نستطيع
أكلَ ما نرغب
لسنا مضطرين أن يكون
إحدى مكونات الحلويات بصلاً
ولا أن يكون كعك العيد
بدون سميد ولا طحين ولا عجوة
ولا أن نتأمل في بصلة وهي
تنمو برغم أنها تستحق
ولا أن أنظر للقمر مع مقدرتي
على رؤيته كل يوم
مع عدم شعوري به
أعتقد أن عدداً كبيراً منا
لا يذكر آخر مرة تأمل فيها شروق الشمس
أذكر أول يوم لي في الحرية
أول شيء عملته
صعدت على سطح المنزل
أراقب شروق الشمس
لم أكن مصدقاً لدرجة أني خفت
أن يكون حلماً
الخطوة الثانية كانت
الذهاب للبحر
بدون مبالغة
كنت أود أن أحضن البحر
وكنت خائفاً
تصفيق
وكنت خائفاً أن يكون حلماً
يسألني الكثير عن عمري
فأقول لهم تاريخ ميلادي
بعد عودتي للحياة مرة ثانية
18/10/2011
عمري أربع سنوات
أريد أن أقول مفارقة
أثناء التحضير لهذه الحلقة
كان معنا الأستاذ سعدي
وسأل سؤالاً
من لا يهمه صعوده على المسرح
من ضمن المتحدثين
رددت عليه وبسرعة: أنا
لا تحدث فرقاً بالنسبة لي
أن أتحدث أم لا
كنت في مكان
ما كنت أقدر تحديد وقت
دخولي للحمام
أقصى طموحي رؤية بصلة
يكون عندي عصفور
أشوف والدتي أحياناً
وقت الزيارة إن استطعت
وأنت تقول لي: تيد إكس شجاعية
أو تيد عالمي
تصفيق
مع ذلك، في هذه الجزئية
أشكر أي إنسان أتاح لي
أن أقف في هذا المكان
فخور جداً أنني من غزة
تصفيق
كنا حريصين أن تيد إكس شجاعية
يكون ناجح
تيد إكس شجاعية ليس عليه أن
يكون ناجحاً فقط
تيد إكس شجاعية
عليه أن يكون ملهماً لكل العالم
لأن كل العالم يعيش ظروفاً طبيعية
وغزة لا تعيش ظروفاً طبيعية
وشكراً
تصفيق